je vais vous raconter une histoire qui
s'est passé il ya très longtemps
c'était juste après l'arrivée des
premiers enfants dans l'île
qu'est ce que vous vous souvenez de
l'histoire qui avait raconté françois un
jour non je l'appelle françois frangins
vient vite à qui at il résumé
voilà je veux raconter une histoire aux
enfants et mais je ne peux pas ça se
passe juste après l'arrivée des premiers
enfants dans l'île et ils ne connaissent
pas l'histoire quasi mis d'accord mais
vas te préparer encore entendu et bien
voilà les enfants cela se passait il y a
environ 400 ans à cette époque là lille
ne s'appelait pas encore l'île aux
enfants et ses habitants les animaux de
toutes espèces dont les plus malins les
plus intelligents et elle est quasi
nulle russe l'avait encore jamais vu
d'hommes
or il y a quatre cents ans c'était
l'époque où conquistadors les grands
explorateurs un jour un avis rejeta
lancre juste devant l'île d'er casimir
us et le commando fit mettre une
chaloupe à la mer et casimir us
décidèrent tous ensemble d'observer sans
se faire voir la façon d'agir des
nouveaux arrivants
malheureusement il ne leur fallut pas
longtemps pour être fixé les soldats qui
venaient de débarquer dans l'île d'er
qassimi russes étaient parmi les plus
féroces des conquistadors casimir reçu
d'abord effrayés de les voir tuer tous
les animaux qui s'approchaient d'eux
avec des armes mystérieuse quitte la
quête comme le tonnerre
en réalité c'était des arquebuse mer les
kassim russe n'avait encore jamais
entendu à coups de fusées cependant de
tous les coins de l'île des groupes
d'animaux arrivait pour demander où
casimir est faire quelque chose alors et
casimir us se sont déguisés en monstres
affreux et regarder un petit peu ce que
ça a donné
casimir
[Musique]
chez les soldats se fait aussitôt la
panique il poussait déroulement de
frayeur qui retentira travers l'île tout
entière se bagarrer pour monter dans les
barques
certains même se sont ouvertes à la nage
le navire le val encre et disparu à
l'horizon les casimir us étaient très
contents mais est aussi très étonné
parce que sur la plage deux petits
soldats étaient restés en réalité
c'était les deux petits mousses du
navire qui ne voulait pas partir il se
rouler dans le sable orientaux ccna et
plus les casimir us faisait des gestes
terrible pour la faire peur plus les
petits mousses trier il devint
rapidement très ami avec les casimir us
quelques temps après des navires de
guerre revers pour venir chercher les
deux petits mousses ceci refusèrent de
partir écrit hier pas question de partir
ici c'est notre île c'est l'île aux
enfants
voilà c'est ici que commence mon
histoire qui veulent attendre les
consignes alors je vais m'asseoir
[Musique]
le grand-père du grand-père de mon
arrière-grand-père réunit alors tous les
chefs de familles d'animaux de lille le
shafia entendre trois longs miaou qui
voulait dire que se passe-t-il grand
chef casimir us à mon grand père le
grand-père du grand-père de mon
arrière-grand-père plus tôt lors dit
alors mes amis je vous ai réunis pour
vous annoncer une grande nouvelle
depuis aujourd'hui notre île a enfin un
nom le lavage fit entendre un grand
moment de stupéfaction et lan fit
entendre heroes qui voulait dire qu'elle
est ce nom le grand-père du grand-père
de mon arrière grand père dit alors
avoir très haute pour que tout le monde
l'entende sono est l'île aux enfants
tous les animaux trouvèrent le ce nom-là
excellents et ils applaudirent est tout
le monde crie
dans sa langue le chef y entendre les
grands mia ou la chouette des who ou ou
le val des dix le lion des gras et
cetera alors mon grand père qui ne
comprenait plus rien leur demander de se
taire dans sa langue et il leur dit mes
amis à partir d'aujourd'hui nous allons
apprendre le langage des enfants et nous
parlerons ce langage dans toutes nos
réunions tous les animaux furent
d'accord les enfants décidèrent de
donner des cours malheureusement seuls
les casimir us réussir a appris à
apprendre le langage des enfants voilà
mais vous savez si un jour vous désirez
parler un lapin est bien venu me voir je
traduirai bravo casimir
elle est vraiment très belle ton
histoire et ses ailes aurait été encore
mieux si tu nous avais donné le nom du
langage de chaque animal ben oui mais je
me souviens toujours du cris des animaux
mais jamais de l'or n'ont été que nous
les cherchons avec les enfants adacore
volontiers d'accord evo6 chez vous
cherchez d'accord alors casimir quand un
chat fait un chat fait miaou miaou ont
dit qu'il n'y en eut dit qu'il me all
bon quand une vache fait elle ne glace
et le nul devant et quand un éléphant
fait un éléphant ah oui il est bien
content année les forfaits comme fait
casimir un éléphant baril maintenant
quand une chouette fait une chouette ça
fait boum
connaissez la réponse elle hull et quand
un cheval fait ea à cheval et oui il est
ni quand un pigeon faire un pigeon ça
fait très bien
il recule il ne glisse pas ils
roucoulent quand un chien il aboie et
quant à lui offert à quoi elle est au à
lyon alors il rugit très bien et un
petit mouton quand il faire
bien il bel et bien tout ça c'était très
facile hein en face il dit pour fait
casimir j'y pense tu nous a pas donné le
nom du langage de kazemi russe au nom du
langage des casimir husson mais c'est
facile voyons tu ne le sais pas françois
enfin c'est c'est tiens j'ai oublié